[Applause]
so we have big things to talk about but
uh first i have to say something it's
somewhat personal but also national news
a friend of mine dear friend of mine
good friend of this show got stabbed
today salman rushdie i'm sure people
have seen this news
he was started by someone named hajj
hadi matar
we don't know the motivation yet but sal
did have some enemies in the past as i
recall
so i'm guessing hadi is not amish
sal was in chattawa he was giving a
lecture how about this for irony about
how the u.s is a safe haven for exiled
writers and other artists under threat
of persecution
and
making that speech itself is unthinkable
in most muslim countries
salman rushi living in most muslim
countries without getting stabbed every
day
is unthinkable
so don't come at me with islamophobic
phobic means fear
right
well sal had a good reason to be fearful
uh and when you say phobic it's just a
way to shut off debate
you know the youth transphobic
islamophobic and we should have a debate
about this
sorry but you know these things don't go
away islam is still a much more
fundamentalist religion than any of the
other religions in the world and that
means
they take what's in the holy book
seriously
and that has been dangerous for a long
time
it's still dangerous
this was 1989 when he was first
threatened
you know they say we have a long memory
and we got just got out i want zawahiri
we were bragging about oh you can't get
away from
they have a long memory too
so what are your thoughts on that
well i want to just draw your attention
to a quote from salman rushdie the
defense of free speech begins at the
point when people say something you
can't stand
you often have to defend people you find
outrageous unpleasant and disgusting
and that's the point i think that people
have forgotten
in this debate about free speech
which is it's not about the right of
people you agree with to say what they
like and then you're not along
it's about your ability to listen to
people whose opinions you might
staunchly disagree with you might hate
their opinions you might hate them
but you should be able to tolerate their
right to have a different opinion
you